[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش كالعاده ابرز
ملفات اليوم وفي ملفات هذا المساء ما الذي
يعرقل جهود المصالحه بين تركيا والنظام
السوري التصعيد في الشمال التركي كما تقول
دمشق في الملف الثاني
الجنسيه البريطانيه هل يزيد الغرب ضغوط
على ظهران ام ان العقوبات ثبت فشلها وفي
الملف الثالث هل تدفع ضغوط الدوليه حركه
الطالبه لاعاده البحث في وضع المراه ام ان
قرار الحركاني
او غير قابل للنقاش
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم الى التفاصيل 11 عاما من القطيعه
بين انقره ودمشق احد عشر عاما من
الاتهامات المتبادله والتحركات والتحركات
المضاده كلها انتهت باعلان تركيا
مع دمشق مسار خريطه الاتصال بين انقره
ودمشق الذي ارتسمت معالمه في الايام
القليله الماضيه بدا باجتماعات الوزراء
الدفاع برعايه روسيا التي تسعى للاعبي
دوري قياديه في مصر عوده العلاقات بين
البلدين وزير الخارجيه التركيين مولود
شاويش اوغلو اجتماعا مع نظيره السوري قد
يعقد في وقت قريب ليس ابعد من شهر فبراير
المقبل لكن الخارجيه السوريه تاكدت ان اي
لقاءات مع الجانب التركي يجب ان تبنى على
اسس احترام السياده الوطنيه
والوحده الترابيه وبان انهاء الوجود
العسكريه التركيه على الاراضي السوريه وهو
شرط اساسي لتحقيق تقارب كامل في العلاقات
بين البلدين اما رايس السوريه بشار الاسد
فراى ان اللقاءات السوريه التركيه يجب ان
تكون مبنيه على انهاء التواجد العسكري
التركي في سوريا وحتى تكون مثمره يجب ان
تبنى على تنسيق وتخطيط مسبق بين الدولتين
التصريحات السوريه تعتبرها البعض ردا على
تصريحات وزير الخارجيه التركي الذي اكد ان
تطور العلاقات مع دمشق مرتبطون باتخذه
خطوات في العمليه السياسيه قبل لقاء
اردوغان بالاسد ووفقه مراقبين فانقره تبحث
عن بدائل سياسيه عن العمل العسكري امالا
بتحقيق تحالفن مع نظامها دمشق
وهو ما يضمن لها تثبيته وجودها العسكري في
مناطق خفض التصحيح
[موسيقى]
هناك هذا الموضوع
دكتور سمير صالح الاستاذ في العلاقات
الدوليه اهلا بك من دمشق عمر راحمون
المتحدث باسم هيئه المصالحه السوريه اهلا
بكما اسمها حالي ان ابدا من اسطنبول معك
دكتور سمير في الواقع بعد تحليلات
وتخمينات خاصه في ظل غياب كما يقول البعض
تصريحات رسميه سوريه عن هذا التقارب
والمامون منه جاءت تصريحات الرئيس السوري
بشار الاسد ووضع شرطا واضح وصريحا تحدث عن
انهاء الاحتلال في رفاي ادلب وحلب
الاحتلال التركي السؤال هل تفعلها تركيا
هل تستجيب
مساء الخير للجميع اولا اهلا بك يعني حسب
انا متابعتي لم ارى حتى الان اي مسؤول
سياسي ولا عسكري تركي ولا حتى في الجانب
السوري كما امم اظن
تحدث عن مصالحه او تطبيع في مسار العلاقات
ربما هي نعم اتصالات برعايه روسيه بدايه
الحوار اذا شئنا بين الجانبين لكن مساله
المصالحه والتطبيعه ليست مساله حوار
الساعه كما انا اظن لماذا لانه كما اشارتي
هذا قبل قليل كل طرف متمسك به العديد من
المواقف
بالشروط طلبات يعلنها
باستمرار اذا المساله ليس بمثل هذه السرعه
والسهوله والبساطه في اكثر من لاعب محلي
اقليمي دولي ايضا على خط الاسماء وفي اكثر
من عامل بشخص سياسي امني اذا شئت ايضا
يعرقل ويعقد هذا النوع من الحوارات الان
كما يبدو كما انا اظن ايضا في ربما جمود
في في الحماس الذي شاهدناه ربما قبل
اسبوعين او ثلاثه اسابيع لماذا ذلك اكثر
من سبب ايضا محلي واقليمي ولكن دكتور سمير
وكان حاضر لك همم يعني همم مع مسار او
مطابق لمسار التصريحات التركيه التي بعد
ان طرحت فكره التقارب والمصالحه وحتى
التطبيع رئيس اردوغان تحدث اكثر من مره عن
ذلك همم كل تصريحات تراجعت وبدا الحديث عن
حوارات ليس اكثر استاذ عمر كيف تقرا حضرتك
الموضوع هل نحن في حضور حوارات لاكثر او
ان الجنب التركي كان منذ البدايه يطمع في
التطبيع الكامل
تحيه لكم
مشاهدين يعني
المسار المصالحه او التطبيع او اعاده بناء
العلاقات او عوده العلاقات الى ما كانت
اليه سابقه قبل بدايه الازمه السوري هذا
في الحقيقه مسار بداته تركيا منذ عام 2016
يعني منذ 2016 حتى الان حتى 2023 ولم يصرح
مسؤول سوري عن هذه العلاقات الا عن لقاء
امن حدث
بالفتره
2019 او 20 وتم التصريح عنهم من قبل
المستشار الرئاسيه شعبان اذا هناك تباطئ
في سوري بالتعاطي مع هذا الملف لان هذا
الطباطؤ طبعا ليس لا يدل على ان سوريا لا
ترغب بعوده العلاقات فلا احد في سوريا او
تركيا او في المنطقه همم يريد قطع
العلاقات بين سوريا وتركيا لان قطع
العلاقات بين سوريا
مبالغ فيه قليلا استاذ عمر لا احد في
سوريا يطمح لعوده العلاقات لاننا تابعنا
احتجاجات كذلك في داخل السوري تعارض هذا
التقارب كان هناك حتى همم عمليه اعتداء
على السيد همم
المسلط لانه كان هناك حديث عن عدم موافقه
على هذا التقارب
يعني
لا احد في سوريا يقصد في المناطق المواليه
للدوله السوريه انا لست معنيا بالحديث عن
المعارضه او عن المستند او الابتلاء او عن
الجمهور هذه المعارضه في الحقيقه
عندما تحدث عن سوريا هنا اتحدث عن الدوله
السوريه وعن المناطق الخاطئه لصديق الدوله
السوريه وبالتالي يعني لا سوريا لا يعني
تريدين ان احدد عندما اقول سوريا سوريا
معروفه بدورتها وحقوبتها وجيشها ورئيسها
المعارضه لها من يتحدث باسمها اذا لا احد
همم
[موسيقى]
اختلطت الاوراق يعني نحن مثلا لما نتحدث
عن تصريحات رئيس السوري همم وجوب خروج
الاحتلال التركي كما اسماء من ادلب ادلب
تتواجد فيها المعارضه
طبعا
عندما ادفى طيب ساكون اكثر وضوحا في في
استخدام المصطلح يعني الدوله السوريه
عندما لا احد في الدوله السوريه ولا في
تركيا ولا في المنطقه او في الاقليم له
مصلحه في استمرار المقاطعه السوريه
التركيه لان الضرر ليس فقط على سوريا
وتركيا فقط بل يضرر على المنطقه كلها
اقليم وك كمنطقه بشكل عام وبالتالي سوريا
تباطئ السوري في التعاطي مع هذه المساله
لا يعني بان سوريا لا تريد المصالحه او
عوده العلاقات مع التركيه بل لان لسوريا
تجربه مريره مع تركيا مع الجانب التركي او
مع حكومه العداله والتنميه مع اردوغان في
المماطله الان نحن في الحقيقه دخلنا في
مسلسل تركي طويل يعني مره يسرع الرئيس
التركي مره يسرح وزير الخارجيه بان بانه
لاعداء في السياسه الى الابد وبانه لابد
ان نجلس مع سوريا او مع رئيس مع الرئيس
السوري ثم
يتحدث البارحه المتحدث باسم الرئاسه
التركيه بانه قد تنطلق العمليه العسكريه
في اي لحظه يعني هذا مسلسل تركي طويل مرات
يتحدثون عن المصالحه ومرات يتحدثون عن
احتلال قديم وعن احتلال جديد المساله ليست
بهذه السهوله طبعا المسلحه وما قرات بانه
تضارب تصريحات تركيا الى ضيف الدكتور
صالحه
يعني الان في اكثر من من عقده في في
التعامل مع هذا الملف لذلك انا قلت لك انه
ذلك في ان نقول او نتحدث انه في رغبه
تركيه او رغبه سوريه في دمشق باتجاه فتح
صفحه جديده من العلاقات هذا الحوار الان
الجميع يعرف انه يتم
بويساطه روسيه بين الطرفين لكن في نقطه
مهمه ايضا يعرفها اكثر من لاعب انه موجود
اللاعب الامريكي موجود بثقلي ايضا في
الملف السوري ايران ايضا ما زالت تحاول ان
تحمي حصتها ونفوضها انا وانت تبعنا زياره
عبد الله يعني الى دمشق
تفاصيل المؤتمر الصحفي المشترك معنا نظيره
السوري في دمشق لذلك يعني ما زلت عند قناه
انه هذا الحوار لا يمكن ان ينتقل من مرحله
الى مرحله دون اخذ بعين الاعتبار لعبه
التوازنات والنقاشات
طابعه اقليمي مثلا بسيطه يعني هل هذا من
سيؤخذها ومن سيتنازل وكيف تبدو الحسابات
وهل تشير حظرتك الى انه من العبث القول
بان سوريا او نظام سوريا يمتلك قراره
وبانه همم هذا القرار هو مرهون املاءات
ايرانيه روسيه امريكيه كذلك قد يقول بعض
نظر الى منطقه شمال سوريا وتواجد الاكراد
فيها همم
سيطرتهم على النصف همم تستغل هكذا
النفوذ الروسي والنفوذ الايراني في سوريا
لصالح النظام مساله معروفه لا تحتاج الى
نقاش براي انا ما قاله وزير الخارجيه
ايراني من دمشق وما قاله المقداد ايضا هي
برسائل ايرانيه مشتركه يعني
ما قيل حول شروط تقدم الى انقره من قبل
السيد المقداد برايه هو كلام ايراني قبل
ان يكون كلام سوري يعود لدمشق لماذا لانه
الان في شعور لدى ايران بانها تخسر
وتتراجع على الارض بثقلها في سوريا لصالح
هذا التقدم الان الجديد ربما خطه
التفاهمات الجديده التي تراها روسيا تزعج
ايران بشكل او باخر لذلك راينا هذا الحراك
الايراني الجديد باتجاه حمايه هذه المصالح
لكن في نقطه باختصار لن اطيل انه اتحدث
قبل قليل عن لعبه التوازنات والمعادلات
الكيميائيه علينا ان ننتظر زياره وزير
الخارجيه التركي مولود شهر
نتائج هذه الزياره وهذا يعني طبعا انه
المساله ليست فقط حوار برعايه روسيه بين
الاطراف بل ايضا هناك لاعب امريكي ايضا
عندهم يقول على فكره بخصوص هذه الزياره
البعث قال بانها تصريحات الرئيس السوري
مؤخرا اتت في اطار الضغط الذي سيسبق هذه
الزياره وما سيحمله جيش اوغلو الى واشنطن
ولكن سالتقد منك نقطه همم التدخلات
الدوليه استاذ عمر همم هل يمكن القول
فعليا بان النظام الاسد النظام السوري همم
فعلا قادر على اخذ قراراته وطرحه نقاطه او
شروطه في همم محاوله هذا التقارب التركي
في غنى عنه او همم هذه الطريقه مجرده من
كل تدخلات الخارجيه
سيئه الكريمه بالنسبه للكريمه التي تحدث
عنها ضيفك بالاخذ بالاعتبار الموازنات
وكذا يعني نحن عندنا في سوريا وفي تركيا
هناك امن قومي تركي وامن قومي سوري اذا
كانت تركيا ترغب بالحفاظ على امنها القوم
التركي من الوجود الكانتون الكردي شرقي
الفرات فعليها التواصل مع الدوله السوريه
وهذه القناعه التركيه هي التي دفعت
اردوغان وحكومه العداله والتنميه الى مد
الجسور مع الحكومه السوريه ومع دمشق
وبالتالي همم اذا الامن القومي التركي غير
مرتبط بارضاء المعارضه هنا المعارضه
السوريه مثلا او ما حدث خلال 10 سنوات اذا
كانت تركيا جاده بحفاظها او بحثها عن
الحفاظ على الامن القومي التركي فعليها ان
تفتح الباب بعد دمشق وان تمد وان تعطي فتح
الباب الشروط التي تلائم هذا هذه العلاقه
اما ان تقوم
بها في هذه المرحله على الاقل سيد عمر
البعض يقرا بان همم في هذه التصريحات
تعجيز للجانب التركي
يعني منذ 10 سنوات كان لبعض المعارضه
يقولون سنصلي في الاردوغان كان يقول سنصلي
في المسجد الاموي والمعارض السوريه كانت
تقول بان سناخذ الحكم خلال اشهر وامريكا
كانت تقول على الاسد ان يرحل بعد هذه
المرحله الان نجد بان الجيش السوري انتشر
على كل الحدود السوريه انتشر على كل
الحدود السوريه اللبنانيه همم انتشر على
معظم الحدود السوريه العراقيه
وهناك مصالح وهناك رغبه هناك همم هناك دول
عربيه عادت الى دمشق تركيا
ان الدوله السوريه انتصر مشروع الدوله على
مشروع ربيع الاخوان المسلمين وبالتالي اذا
كانت يعني في الحقيقه المصالحه هذه لم
تطلبها سوريا وسوريا منذ سبع سنوات 2016
ولن تصرح
لا عند بعد اجتماع وزير الدفاع السوري
والتركي اذا نقول لا لا يزال هناك الكثير
من العقبات لا هناك بكثير من المشاكل هناك
الكثير مما حدث على هامش هذا الربيع
التخريبي في خلال عشر سنوات وبالتالي لابد
من اللقاء ولا بد من اجتماعات ولا بد من
الكثير من التواصل حتى يمكن حتى هذه
الملفات هذه الملفات العالقه خلال العشر
سنوات لا يمكن حلها باجتماع هنا واجتماع
وزير الخارجيه او وزير الدفاع هناك حدود
طويله بين سوريا وتركيا 900 كيلو متر هناك
مشاكل هناك فصائل الارهابيه تم دعمها من
تركيا هناك
انفصال شرق الافرازات بدعوه من امريكا
وحل هذه المشاكل لا تكون بالتنافر
معك دكتور سمير ضيف يتحدث عن ان المجال لا
زال مفتوح ولكن هذا المجال يجب ان يبنى
على مفاوضات حوارات حال حلو المشاكل او
تحاول ايجاد حلول همم هل تعتقد بانه لازال
هناك امل في تقارب في تطبيع كل بين تركيا
وسوريا
يعني انا احداتك قبل قليل عن حوار مساله
التطبيع او المصالحه الحقيقيه
برايي بعيده جدا في هذه المرحله الاولى
اتحدث حتى عن المدى المتوسط مثلا البدء
بمفاوضات البدء بطرح نقاط وفيما بعد
لا اظن انا اظن انه الحوار الذي تجريع
انقره بالدرجه الاساسيه في الملف السوري
الان هو مع الجانب الروسي ومع الجانب
الاميركي يعني لولا هذا الحوار التركي
الروسي لم اظن انه انقره يعني قد قررت
الدخول في حوار مع دمشق الضمانات التي
تقدمها موسكو لعنقره هي التي تشجعها ربما
على السير باتجاه
دمشق لكن حتى الان كما قلت لك المساله
الشروط والمطالب ما زالت موجوده مثلا مثلا
انسحاب القوات التركيه او سحب القوات
التركيه من شمال سوريا يعني كيف يعني من
الممكن ان تناقش مساله من هذا النوع ونحن
نعرف انه نوميشيات حزب الله
الحشد الشعبي جاءت في العمليات العسكريه
التي ينفذها النظام للقتال على الحدود
السوريه
هذه النقطه لا نقاش اولها حزب الله لا
اعرف باي قناه سيادي حزب الله دخل الى
سوريا ما هي مشروعيه وجودها او وجود
ميليشيات عراقيه في سوريا لا اطلاقا هذه
المساله ليست مرتبطه بالسياده ولا اظن
اطلاقا وضيفه يعرف ذلك
يستمع لك ولكن غير موافق على العديد من
النقاط همم ساعتذر منك استاذ عمر لانه
انتهى تماما توقيت الخاص لهذا الملف ولكن
اكيد باننا سنكون في نقاشاتنا قادمه بخصوص
هذه التطورات المهمه شكرا لكما من دمشق
عمر ارحمونا المتحدث باسم هيئات المصالح
السوريه ومن اسطنبول الدكتور سامي صالح
الاستاذ في العلاقات الدوليه شكرا
[موسيقى]